is it time for us to go into the vp
debate and just kind of
talk about the vp debate here okay so if
you're watching this
i saw a bunch of the scores you guys
posted by the way we got 50
from let me see ricky bobby's on with us
today guys
ricky bobby is on the podcast tell you
if you ain't first or last
it first your last you want to gain too
want to go fast
you want to go to 500 000 subscribers
start talking about the independent
contractors that haul freight
we never stop well thank you ricky bobby
for that fifty dollars
uh uh that you put out the lunches on
ricky bobby yeah it is so so let's get
right into it gang
okay so what was the score i saw a bunch
of scores up there somebody said zero
zero
someone said 29 27 what was the vp
debate score
did it keep you going did you like it
more than the presidential debate so
prior to going on to all the issues kai
if you if you want to pull up all the
topics that they debated
pull that up the topics that was uh
discussed on a vice presidential debate
uh let me see what you got here do you
have any notes here yourself kind of vp
debate or no is there anything he asked
here or no
nothing really here okay so last night's
debate what do you think about it
do you want my score or you want to know
okay it's not fair to ask me this
question by the way because i am a
professional sports commentator
okay so if i give you a score and it's a
metaphor for a football game you know
i'm gonna be right tell us so i already
won this it was 25 to three
25 to three also before you say who
wants you obviously
you obviously lean very far no i don't i
i
evaluate what i see i evaluate and i'm
gonna tell you
here's why it's 25 to three he scored
four touchdowns
four he missed three extra points okay
so he's not perfect he's not even
really that good wow terrible but yeah
bad kicker
it's the little things it's the
fundamentals sometimes um
yeah 20 and she got a she she got a late
field goal i mean look
i was i was not i did not think it was a
great debate maybe the bar was set
so low from the first presidential
debate but at least
that was compelling it mattered now this
one may matter because of the age of the
real presidential candidates
which frightens me even more you know
after watching that but i didn't think
it was a great debate i didn't think the
moderator did a fantastic job
um i didn't think they brought a lot and
we can get into more details but i'm
gonna give it a score of 25 three pence
typical tom over here let's see what you
got let's see your score buddy
i got a hundred to zero kamala just
kidding
relax i got i got 1313 as a tie in
overtime there was no
clear winner i thought that was a debate
that first debate between trump and
biden was a
absolute [ __ ] show sorry if you're under
18 listen to this show yeah
complete [ __ ] show trump acting like a
baby biden
couldn't hold it together that was
disgusting this was a real debate they
actually was substantive
they actually covered a lot of ground
they each had a couple different good
points i could
kind of go what i thought some good
points were i'm sure we'll get into it
but there was two things that they each
needed to do
pence i think i thought pence did a
better job defending trump's record than
trump
did straight up pence i mean if if i
ever
have a vice president if i ever want to
run a company i want someone like pence
by my side no matter how fwc
it's 13-13 okay yes because kamala did a
great
job because what was kamal's job what
was her point to do that
all she has to do is hold serve she
doesn't need she didn't parent her to
the left
she said she says i agree with fracking
i'm good
that's called a lie in the american it
is is it like
she said just a few months ago that she
i'm just saying that's what she said
there
so yeah but that's all she held that's a
lie buddy buddy
pence goes there and just lies like
crazy
trump doesn't lie like crazy no no tell
us how pens slide
i didn't say trump tell us how pence
like let's talk about the super spreader
event at the white house at the rose
garden okay let's just talk about that
yeah who's the head of the coronavira
task force
himself pence okay he said when they
said do you take any blame for
basically 25 people in the close close
close to the cabinet yeah
got coveted kaylee mcilhenny hope hicks
yeah trump himself his wife i think
that's right ridiculous no
i think half his cabinet has covet are
you freaking kidding me i think and
pence is in charge
that's why they made that the first
topic because they knew they were going
to lose people after the first topic and
she gave
kamala a very easy soft softball here
you go
soft pitch here go hit this one here and
she opened it up with her line that she
had prepared because she knew the first
time
was the line what was the line yeah she
came out of saying this
is the worst handling of a crisis we've
ever seen in the history of america
you know i'm prefacing what you said but
something like that is what came out
so set the whole thing up but but tell
me about you
talking about the lies that lack of
responsibility but lies with pens
number one he talked about the v-shaped
economy the recovery we know that it's
not a v-shape recovery maybe the
stock market is v-shaped maybe the rich
are getting richer but it's clearly a
k-shaped
economy okay okay we talked about how he
tried to
compare what's happening with covid but
the freaking v-shape
economy is a v-shape the stock market is
the stock market the stock market isn't
the economy though it's a reflection of
the economy a reflection but it's not
unemployment went from eight point three
to seven point nine six hundred sixty
one thousand there's still 20 million
people unemployed though but you already
employed half of them though
you ain't going to do it in two months
how are you gonna employ all these
people and you you want him to do it in
two months
are you kidding me i mean it's been
seven months since covet started no it's
since of course since kovitz started
what i'm saying is from the peak
from the peak you want that recovery two
months it took it took
obama years to recover from what he had
would bush so you can make the recovery
body it's being recovered
fairly quickly for what they have the
stock market for sure and this
and main street jobs as well yeah i mean
we i'm sure but i want to tell lies i
want to know specifically pence's lies
tell me where pence lied
where i thought he number one he he
ducked
many questions so did she so did she
so so did kamala like when they asked
the king of pence was very different
than kamala
kamala when it came to she don't have a
court she
she she bobbed and weave like she was
muhammad ali straight up
pence would just not answer a question
they asked them repeatedly
have you discussed um a uh
uh um plan like a succession plan
what happens didn't answer the question
didn't answer trump's health the one
with yes
did not answer the question did not
answer the question whatsoever
the fact that he tried to correlate h1n1
swine flu to what's happening now is
beyond laughable
tell me why are you kidding me how many
people died of the h1n1 buddy it's not
the point of how many people died
the the the swine flu wasn't as deadly
as this if it was those 60 million cases
that got it if the same rate applied as
covet
two million people would have died if if
it's not about the if it's about the
fact that you let it spread
that's the part it's about you let it
spread and nobody shut down the economy
it was 60 million cases they got lucky
it wasn't deadly
how do you know how deadly a virus is
i'm not here to defend no but i'm not
i'm not here to i'm not a
i will tell you what reality is i'm just
saying the swine flu is nothing i will
tell you where pence lost i will tell
you what happens no but what i'm trying
to say is when it comes on to
let me tell you what i did last night
here's what i did last night and i told
this to generalization when i went to
bed and by the way
for those of you guys that are watching
this for me my opinion
it's one of the best debates i've ever
seen okay in a long time okay
and what when i say i'm talking uh for
me it's the best vp debate ever that
i've seen i mean i'm 41 years old i
haven't been around for a long time i
thought it was a great vp debate
here's how i watched it i tweeted out
yesterday i said
i said pence doesn't seem
like a vp pence seems presidential
he doesn't look like a vp pence is the
kind of guy that if your son said i want
to grow up to be like pence you would
say
okay no problem sounds like a really
good guy sometimes on the other side
like let me tell you man trump inspired
a lot of people to be trumps
you know what i mean a lot of a lot of
people are like live kids trump's doing
it i'm gonna do it as well
you know sometimes when somebody takes a
new president that becomes a president
people take after that person's
personality
you know when obama was president you
were kind of like okay cool
you know my boy wants to grow up to be
like obama i'm good with that
you know because he was what he was a
suave yeah you know
i want to grow up to be like bill
clinton yeah i don't i don't know about
that buddy you know you may want to
think twice but maybe you one day be a
part of what's wrong with bill clinton
well you know some of the
ways personal life all this stuff you're
like i'm good with it i'm not about i'm
not listen i voted for the guy so i'm a
guy i'm a fan of bill clinton if i put
bill and let's just say trump together
okay when i'm not as a leader remember i
am very logical in
policies i don't go emotion some of the
parties go emotional i don't go in
motion i go policies
i watch the debate they said i'm like
dude let me tell you
i would have no problem with my kids
sitting there my eight seven and four
year old sitting there listening to the
whole day i'm not comfortable then
watching the other debate
but if they watch your lesson like okay
issues that what is that that what is
vaccine
dad what is this i love that we had a
conversation together right okay
here's the other part i watched him
and i said try hating him
try hating pants you can't do it a
rational person no
no a rational person yeah try hating the
guy you can't do it yeah
i say try hating trump
what's the answer very very easy to do
well it's the biggest topic
i mean yeah but what i'm saying is like
the way he comes in let me tell you i'm
the best and i'm perfect like right now
even this morning with mario bartoroma
he's like
my health has never been better in 20
years dude you're 20 years older what do
you mean your health has never been
better
my health feels perfect but i feel
perfect the keyword perfect perfect
you've got covered
so what i'm trying to tell you but i
understand why some people may not like
his personality
i support policies i don't go
personality pence to me
was presidential yesterday kamala every
time she was
losing she had that big laugh the big
laugh
she goes like this i think i got caught
let me laugh like it's not a big deal
and then
boom she didn't have an answer it would
happen twice both times there was one
time where
joe kept bringing up her record as a
prosecutor that's what she did as a and
that was
she kept doing this she kept looking at
the moderator like hey change the
subject
it's like hey okay vice president mr
vice president
she's just looking to be saved and says
i will not be lectured
here to be undermined for my record you
asked me to score you asked me to score
28 seven pence killed it twenty-eight
not even close
not even bro the fact that the way he
reacted
when they took shots was so imp
you cannot learn that skill he's just
kind of standing there he's like thank
you susan
you know uh first of all when i saw you
uh my wife and i celebrated when i saw
you being selected and doing this this
was an incredible i wanted to
congratulate you in front of everybody
it was like oh thank you thank you and
you know but at the same time
uh look uh kamala harris you may have
the right to your opinions but you don't
have to write your
you know your truth in fact it just went
through and the way he did it you're
like
this is how this guy's gonna negotiate
behind closed doors are you kidding me
i'm good with this guy the way handles
it it seems so
presidential do you think he would ever
after trump yes
you think he would ever a run for
president and b do you think he has any
chance of being elected i do
you think so i do well yeah i do but he
has to pick his vp the other way around
by the way yeah yeah yeah
he's a wild man as his vp i don't know
but he needs to pick his vp the way
trump
is you know he would never have a woman
as a vp never how do you know that
because you can't spend more time i
literally cannot be alone in a room with
a woman
i respect that you know a couple things
about that you know when no one knew who
pence was when trump picked him and
maybe there was a method to the madness
because he almost is the perfect counter
balance
and you saw that last night just in
their personalities you mentioned pat
that how can you hate him you should see
some of the tweets from hollywood
joy behar ellis and milana yeah they
hate them
i mean i'm not surprised isn't it i mean
it's unbelievable but you got to realize
i understand why
yeah here's my biggest problem with
kamala last night why i think she got
hammered is a
she lied okay joe biden did not save the
auto industry
i don't know how you can go up there and
just make that comment that joe biden
saved the audio
auto industry you know she's completely
lying about fracking they are going to
stop fracking a hundred percent
um i thought did did pence miss an
opportunity by bringing up the fact that
uh she called joe biden a racist during
the presidency he missed a lot of
opportunities i mean that was the
biggest
opportunity that he missed and he's
never going to get a chance to do it
again i thought that was
a huge gaffe by him and then my biggest
problem with her
when the moderator asked her about china
and made the question
as specific as you could possibly be are
they an adversary an enemy
a competitor she didn't even mention the
word china yeah i mean she didn't even
answer it and that answered the question
to me that
she's in cahoots yeah here's here's what
you got to think about kai if you can
pull up the
the topics that was brought up here's
here's how you got to think about that
so what is this this
is uh the vp i want the vp one
is this is this a vp debate and these
are the topics right okay let's go and
look at the topics
let's go look at the topics go down okay
go down uh
uh what was the one you had i just saw a
different one that okay is that the one
that it is okay
uh so tr they talk about trump fine
covet 19. so okay
let's just say trump let's just say
trump is a difficult person to defend
and i thought
no one in the world could have done a
better job defending trump than pence i
don't think he could have said a better
thing defending his president
i think he crushed it i think he may be
one of the best number two guys i've
seen in a long time
if i ever have a number two i want a guy
like that no doubt oh by the way i also
thought kamala did a very good job
always bringing her back to joe i
thought she did a fantastic job saying
and under a joe biden administration and
i think joe biden is this and one of the
things about joe
she was doing she had a great job being
a flag it's not about have to
it's you have to know how to do that i
thought she did a phenomenal job on that
side defending her
candidate uh when they talked about uh
covert 19 they spend the most time
talking about sure that makes sense
that's what we're going through
then the economy and then biden supreme
court election race foreign policy
you know what's keep going down keep
going down keep going down keep going
down keep going down
look how much time they spend talking
about china 45 seconds 45 seconds
about abortion 43 seconds
43 seconds they should have spent more
time on it because roe versus wade i
mean that's something that's going to be
uh what they're worried about with the
uh the supreme yeah stacking the court
but china you got 90 minutes the number
one enemy
okay the cause of this and susan
couldn't ask
more questions about china all i wanted
to know about was china it was like
china was like this
oh china okay okay okay let's go let's
go let's go terrible at follow-ups she
was horrible
she just didn't want to interrupt them
and she wanted to make sure that they
weren't overgoing on their time i mean
that was her big
by the way i tell you even though i know
she leans left i thought she did a good
job
i i'm not going to sit inside of course
she interrupted
uh pence a lot more than kamala and when
kamala's like i need time to respond
she she gave it to her but she didn't
give it to him
there was those couple minutes where she
got too much like okay
i'll give you 30 seconds but he would
say i'll give you 15 seconds but he
would say i would give you 30. he would
keep going over the clock no
but he has to you know what he has but
he never raised his voice when he did it
she kept saying thank you thank you so
thank you
i kept saying i'm speaking that's what
i'm speaking that's it it's more of a
mental gift than anything to be able to
allow yourself questions
you know when i watch kamala harris and
i look i'm just stating the facts here
i can totally understand how she didn't
even make it to her home state
for a primary you know for the democrats
i mean she was not good she's not good
on stage she's not believable i find her
condescending
i mean that's it's scary to think
that um that she's that close and
and biden thought that highly of her
after everything that went down between
them personally
[Music]
you